you had one job
in my head you were so much better with
balls
do you picture your career this way when
you start out is like what you want not
here
julia roberts you live next to me at the
beach you know that thanks for all the
visits
anyway uh i'm living about two blocks
from
the broad never shows up come by and say
hello we're closer than two blocks i
have no lines julia just not
anyway i once thought
pete davidson was just like obama
biracial goofball who ruined a once
beloved
institution but it turns out i was wrong
pete's not biracial
good one and now for the man of the hour
just imagine a world where i'm george
clooney that's it
no just imagine that world for a second
you're not okay all right i asked you
you use your imagination right now
yeah and i know i'm a guest on your
podcast but there's
no [ __ ] way that you're george
clooney they're not in the same
category i think you're not ugly you're
not ugly but you're not george clooney
but tonight we're kicking it off with
two of the biggest names with the
smallest bodies and the biggest dicks in
comedy
david spade and kevin hart
you got melania a huge 12 carat diamond
engagement ring you should not have
gotten her a diamond now she knows what
hard is supposed to feel like
well i went to private school so i never
did go like my teacher never went on
strike so
you went to private school yeah well
that wasn't a waste of money
sugar ray is a great champion sugar we'd
ask you to talk but you know the blacks
your lips lock
you know him from tough crowd with colin
quinn and that's it
please welcome the virtually anonymous
greg geraldo that was great jim i've
never seen you be funny on tv before
have some dignity and stick to radio you
look like pete sampras with down
syndrome
and katie seagal you're an incredible
actress
you worked on married with children the
show that changed comedy
sons of anarchy the show that took drama
to a whole new level
and eight simple rules the show that
killed john ritter
i gotta ask you a question the hat it's
one thing to wear the hat
backwards do you have an afro under that
or something it looks
uh it looks very very high i'll tell you
what
that hey that's none of your damn
business okay
whatever's going on up under my hat is
none of your business
the only information that you need to
know is that i don't have a mushroom on
the top of my head like you
that's right stephen a i have a cut from
this year
all right from this era from this
generation i don't even know what i'm
going to say before i say it it just
flies out of my mouth
is that how does that work what happens
when you find yourself in a situation
where
sincerity is paramount well
the way you're looking at me makes me
want to cover up my vagina
madam if i had rubber gloves i'd do it
for you
you look like an italian dude that
drowned and then just still lived
how about a zombie yeah you [ __ ] look
like i was like
your whole career as a comedian is about
making fun
of pretentious high-minded
self-congratulatory bs events like this
one
the whole feeling in this room of
reverence and honoring is the exact
opposite of everything i have wanted my
life to be about
de niro is sitting there god bless you
bob he's got the beard on
to know him is a treat he's one of the
great actors of our time you ask him
uh the irishman
was amazing it was amazing um look
it was my face it was great
[Music]
long but amazing um
it wasn't the only epic movie once upon
a time in hollywood nearly three hours
long
leonardo dicaprio attended the premiere
and by the end
his date was too old for him so
and here i am you know i look out i see
president bill clinton you know i see
secretary of state madeleine albright
you know media mogul rupert murdoch
you know broadcast legend larry king you
know
pornographer larry flint you know
dick morris the list is starting to drop
off a little folks but
still you get the idea it's daunting
[Music]
i hope i can say this without insulting
you yes you are no
you're the weirdest looking person on
the planet earth thank you thank you
that doesn't
no that doesn't help me at all that's
that's very kind i don't mean that as
a no negative it does nobody i can't
describe the fact that i have a full
head of hair that's what's going on well
yeah sure sure
i don't mean that in a bad way
i'm not it's just i just don't have to
cover my chin because i'm proud of it
if you weren't famous and you robbed a
bank yeah and the dude was describing
you to like a
police sketch artist yeah he'd be like
no seriously what did he look like
nobody nobody looks like this
nobody looks like you i can't i can't
believe i'm looking at you all the time
clint i say it nobody else has said it
and i say it from my heart
you're a lousy actor
how are you doing bro i'm not too bad at
all i see you've come dressed for
presenting spring watch
see one of the problems i'm running into
with the show is the audiences are so
sweet
and i appreciate that but sometimes they
don't understand that i like to get
i like to get my balls my balls broken
i think it's cool that you think that
you only have one problem on the show
remember the words of a great negro i
say that honestly
all peoples are alike we are all working
you live in my neighborhood i live in
yours right sam right
are you crazy how many women do you
think you've had sex with
anyone do you think more than me or less
than
way more than you this guy's a [ __ ]
[ __ ] machine
way more than you you [ __ ] fat [ __ ]
why are you on your [ __ ] mind it's
not even
thanks for having me you know i uh i was
so excited to be here and see
shaq and emma and hang out with all
these comedians i feel like i died and
went to harlem
this ain't a roast it's a barbecue
have you gone to a clippers game this
year i've gone to several clippers games
how come you haven't mentioned that well
because hey you didn't give me a chance
to
don't cut me off i wasn't done i wasn't
done
you stopped me and then you started
doing some stuff i said to several teams
within those several teams the clippers
was in that you would know that if you
knew if you knew
talking if you knew about this world you
would know that that's what i meant
steve
okay what you do is assume that's your
problem you assume
the clippers are playing great
i basketball i think that the clip is a
great place right now you want to go
howard stern
has been in radio so long he bought
robin at an
auction
hey i'm not supposed to be roasted
why do we laugh black away because we
must laugh that's right
look who became the priest
alec i first saw you in the movie pearl
harbor
which was worse than the actual pearl
harbor
halfway through i was rooting for the
japanese